okay guys we want to talk about what is
ketosis a little bit more on this topic
ketosis is this when you avoid consuming
glucose or sugar for 10 to 12 hours your
body will then start to make ketones
okay ketones are basically the byproduct
of fat burning and you can even test
yourself on ketones there's these strips
you can get at the drugstore called
ketone strips and you check your urine
it'll be like in a different shade of
purple so if it's really dark purple
it's like major ketosis if it's light
purple it's minor ketosis so you can
check to see if you're burning fat or
not the thing that you need to know is
when we convert our body from sugar to
fat it takes between three days to two
weeks up to six weeks depending how long
you've been around your body and sugar
in other words your body has to create
new machinery in the cells so it's very
similar to let's say you're running your
house on coal to heat it right and then
we're going to have to run it on
electric fuel electric heating I'm sorry
not fuel you're going to have to install
new machinery hook up wires to be able
to run your body the same thing with
running you're buying a fat fuel this is
like diesel fuel or coal it's very dirty
this is like solar or electric cars very
clean no waste quiet so to do this it
could take anywhere from one week to six
weeks okay so in the process I'm going
to be showing you what to do because if
you don't do this correctly you could
end up with a lot of issues okay so
we're going to show you how to do it
healthily but but here's the thing when
we run our body on a ketones it's much
more stable with your blood sugars you
won't have the highs and lows anymore so
you're going to be very level-headed
your brain is going to love it your
your memories going to be sharper you
lot you you'll just be right there all
the time better focus more efficient
fuel less dirty less complications
ketones are the original fuel source
it's the original fuel of the brain our
bodies long ago ran an ketones why
because we could necessarily eat all the
sugar that we had we didn't eat three
meals a day or six meals a day we didn't
eat the junk food so our bodies
originally were designed to run on
ketones not sugar it's only till very
recently that we've been eating sugar so
we're going to go back to what your body
is designed to to run on and it's it's
much better I will never go back to
running my body and sugar because once
you feel feel the benefits you won't go
back now the other thing is that ketosis
pretext protein in other words when you
go on this eating plan it's you're not
going to have to worry about your body
eating up your own protein that's only
when you have insulin so your body's not
going to convert protein into fat so
people are just concerned am I going to
lose muscle mass no no you're going to
gain muscle mass your ligaments tendons
collagen is going to get better now
what's going to happen
you can lose a lot of weight with this
program the thing is that let's say you
didn't lose a lot of weight doesn't
necessarily you didn't burn fat but the
best indicator because what's happening
is you could actually gain muscle mass
and lose fat and actually weigh the same
because muscle weighs more than fat so
the best indicator to know it's working
is the ketone strips or a tape measure
around your waist at the very outer
parsh portion so you check the waist
every week and you can measure and see
how many inches you lost that's the
ultimate measurement of success okay
because who cares what you weigh if you
can get a flat stomach so the problem is
it's going to be very expensive you have
to get rid of all your old clothes your
old belt your old suits your shirts get
all new clothes it's going to be very
very expensive you can blame me okay so
when you do this also your
get rid of a lot of excess fluid now
sugar always follows fluid and or fluid
follows sugar so if you get rid of all
the sugar you're going to get rid of the
fluid as well okay so when you get rid
of fluid you're going to lose you might
lose up to I don't know ten pounds in
the first week some people lose ten
pounds that's fluid the most fat that
you can burn per week is two pounds
that's in a healthy body anything more
it's just fluid so anyway I wanted to
kind of explain the timeframe it takes
what we're trying to do we're trying to
switch over to ketones it's a better
fuel source and let's let's show you the
next next video